installé sur ce site de 30 hectares
depuis 1988 bouygues construction a
profité du paris saclay sprint pour
dévoiler son siège et ses activités au
cours d'une matinée un circuit de
l'innovation en petits groupes crise
sanitaire oblige est divisé en deux
parties
les participants ont pu découvrir
notamment le travail du groupe pour
rendre les territoires plus connectés et
durable internet a reconnectés est un
territoire qui intègre des technologies
qui connectent l'ensemble des
infrastructures qui sont à sa
disposition des infrastructures de vidéo
protection des signalisations de feux
tricolores d'éclairage public
les bâtiments de la ville et tous et la
communique au sein d'un hyperviseur
central qui permet d optimiser la
gestion des saisons fera structure un
parcours qui s'est poursuivie au design
lab une nouvelle salle présente sur le
site
l'objectif montrer ce que la technologie
peut apporter au monde de la
construction notamment grâce aux outils
de réalité virtuelle et augmentée
tout ceci nous permet soit d'améliorer
notre qualité sur les chantiers
d'assister les personnes sur les
chantiers pour implanter des ouvrages
pour travailler plus facilement soit
également en amont comment on peut aider
le client à se projeter sur le bâtiment
terminé alors qu'il n'est pas encore
construit et la vingtaine de
participants a pu tester ces
technologies
on voit vraiment ce qui se passe au
niveau au niveau technologique et on
peut partager avec les autres
c'est vraiment bien immersif c'était
l'occasion pour moi de voir ce qui se
faisait autour de smart city et ce matin
était intéressante parce que voilà il ya
un environnement de démo on voit aussi
des îles applications concrètes
proposées ce vendredi 21 mai dont le
cadre du paris saclay springs et
circuits de l'innovation se sont
déroulés en tout dans 10 entreprises et
grands groupes du territoire